hallöle liebe Freunde des Minecraft
Spielens und willkommen zu einer neuen
Mod Review auf dem Kanal concrafter von
mir und zwar handelt es sich dabei
diesmal um den Smart moving Mod für die
Minecraft
1.0.0 der et halt viele neue Animationen
wie z.B dass das Hochklettern auf
Leitern und viel realistischer ist ihr
könnt nun drei Blöcke Höhe hoch klettern
es gibt ein Slalom den ihr besser
bewältigen könnt ihr könnt besser
schwimmen besser fallen besser fliegen
und halt noch viel viel mehr und ich
fange erstmal an mit den Leitern und
zwar wenn ihr den Mod drin habt könnt
ihr einfach Leitern hochklettern und ihr
seht schon der Nikolaus kann toll weit
Leitern hochklettern und ja ihr könnt
die halt dann auch wieder runtergehen
und auch wieder runterklettern und ja
hier so das runterklettern und das
Hochklettern
ähnelt sich sehr bzw sieht eigentlich
sogar gleich aus und ja sieht halt ganz
lustig aus ist ein bisschen mehr
Realismus so nun könnt ihr wenn ihr
sprintet einerseits und danach springt
und danach eine grabtaste die könnt ihr
in den Options controls und hier
einstellen da habe ich jetzt einfach mal
F genommen kann ich nur empfehlen laäuft
einfach drauf zu springt und haltet dann
F gedrückt und dann klettert der hier
hoch relativ langsam aber ihr kommt halt
drei Blöcke hoch ihr könnt euch auch
einfach da vorstellen hüpfen F gedrückt
halten und dann da hoch dauert nur etwas
länger wie ich finde ich weiß nicht ob
es wirklich länger dauert
aber na ja ich finde es dauert länger so
wenn ihr allerdings hier drunter her
wollt seid ihr sonst mal außen rum
gegangen oder habt euch drunter her
gegraben nun haltet ihr einfach Shift
gedrückt und die eure Grab key Taste und
dann könnt ihr einfach hier drunter her
krabbeln jetzt mit W gedrückt der Maus
aber es geht halt nur mit einem Blöcke
großen Lücken z.B wenn ihr 0,5 habt z.B
noch ein Stone slap oder so dann geht
das natürlich nicht das ist jetzt
allerdings relativ langsam deswegen
könnt ihr auch sprinten mit Doppel W
danach hüpfen in der Luft F gedrückt
halten wenn ihr auf dem Boden aufkommt
Shift gedrückt halten das ist ziemlich
schwierig ich weiß nicht ob ich den
Sprung jetzt schaffe ja ich habe es
geschafft los los los los so also dann
kann man halt auch hier drunter her
rutschen und es ist halt relativ selten
dass man diesen Spruch Sprung auch
schafft ihr seht das hier oh jetzt schon
wieder und BAM direkt durch die beiden
Bäume na ja also so könnt ihr halt auch
hier drunter her und halt das alles ein
bisschen schneller so und jetzt noch mal
zur Demonstration tada ich kletter hier
oben drüber so das nächste was kommt ist
der parkcour und zwar seid ihr sonst mal
in so ein parkcours irgendwie so
rumgelaufen oder so halt ziemlich
umständlich
dieser Mod macht euch das Leben halt
viel einfacher ihr habt's gerade schon
ein bisschen gesehen ihr lauft da
einfach ganz schnell W mit Doppel W
wieder in sprintmodus wenn ihr nach
links dann hüpfen wollt also wenn
Hindernis rechts ist und ihr nach links
ausweichen wollt macht ihr Doppel a und
wenn das Hindernis links ist und ihr
wollt nach rechts ausweichen halt Doppel
D hier in der Demonstration so Doppel D
Doppel a Doppel D und dann wieder hier
Doppel a und Doppel W a ach keine Ahnung
viel zu viele Tasten so Doppel a Doppel
W Doppel a Doppel D Doppel a Doppel D so
also da könnt ihr halt viel schneller an
solchen Hindernissen wirklich mal
einfach vorbeigehen und müsst nicht
außen rum laufen und das sieht natürlich
auch viel eleganter aus wenn ihr da so
macht anstatt so hier außenrum das ist
natürlich doof so
dann kommen wir auch schon zu einer der
letzten Sachen na ja es geht und zwar
könnt ihr einen Körper machen ihr
klettert einfach hier wieder die Leiter
hoch so was ihr nun macht ihr sprintet
los und in der Luft haltet ihr euren W
und die Leertaste gedrückt also ihr
sprintet we ah nee mist das ist nämlich
auch ein schwerer Sprung Sprung das ist
hier alles es bringt zwar Realismus in
die Welt mit rein allerdings sind die
ganzen Sprünge noch etwas
schwer so
äh ah das war jetzt auch doof ich probi
es mal noch einmal ob ich dann nicht den
Körper schaffe oder ich probi es mal
hier an Land und zwar müsste das nämlich
eigentlich so gehen so so zack also ihr
sprintet einfach haltet F und Leertaste
gedrückt und lass dann Leertaste los das
ich habe nur den Körper hier oben den
Körper den sprut ein bisschen Zu klein
gebaut um das wirklich umsetzen zu
können ja so und zack dann seid ihr habt
ihr halten Körper gemacht und jetzt kann
ich euch auch die schwimmanimation
zeigen und was ihr seht ihr könnt nun
wirklich deutlich tiefer Schwimmen so
ihr seid jetzt schon in diesem Block da
unten drin und es ist auch realistischer
weil ihr werdet wirklich von dem
Sauerstoff im Wasser nach oben getrieben
wer Chemie oder Physik hat weiß das was
ich da meine okay das müsste eigentlich
jeder wissen und wir machen natürlich
die Tür zu und ja so
nun ihr könnt ich bin nämlich gerade im
Creative Mode und da geht das halt
relativ einfach ihr könnt nun auch so
nach unten fliegen und so wieder nach
oben wie so ein Flugzeug wie eine
flugzeugsteuerung in GTA oder so
und mit le gedrückter Leertaste fliegt i
nach oben und shift halt fliegt i so
cool nach unten sieht halt alles auch
realistischer aus wie der ganze Mod Halt
und was ich euch jetzt noch zeigen
wollte das allerletztes die
fallanimation wenn ich jetzt nämlich das
Fliegen ausmache fällt der Typ nach
unten und ist dann hier wieder in der
wasseranimation also es ist wirklich ein
total cooler Mod ein Lob an den
Entwickler hat er wirklich einen super
Job bei gemacht ihr habt die Links von
den Downloads in der Beschreibung ihr
braucht da nämlich die
AP Datei für ihr braucht den Mod an sich
und ihr braucht halt allgemein den
Modloader dafür um das ganze zum laufen
zu bekommen ihr findet allerdings ganz
ganz viele Tutorials im Internet von
daher ähm sollte es kein Problem sein
dass ihr es hinkriegt wenn ihr jetzt son
nicht hinkriegt dann schreibt mich
einfach an bei Fragen ich hoffe euch hat
das Video gefallen ich würde mich in
jedem Fall über einen Daumen hoch oder
ein wenn ihr das Video als Favorit
hinzufügt freuen wenn nicht dann lasst
es einfach und mit diesen ganzen schönen
Animationen sage ich da mal Tschüss bis
im nächsten Video